welcome back to new rockstars miss
marvel is finally here and beginning the
amount of cosmic-powered heroes within
the mcu and as our powers manifested at
avengers con a place that i would like
to go to very much i couldn't help but
wonder why we're people dressed up as
loki the man who terrorized new york
just of the next door neighbor why are
they doing that new jersey don't do that
new jersey that's not very nice the
general public vmc doesn't know what we
know he attacked new york like don't
dress up as a real world villain yasikos
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
growing rogue with me today is someone
who will always cosplay as a villain
it's jessica clemens what's going on
jess hi
not much i just kicked my [ __ ]
computer i mean my freaking computer oh
yeah we're good what a villain what a
villain listen be nice to your computer
because uh the day that the robot
apocalypse begins uh they're gonna start
with you first
be nice damn straight and a man who was
walking away with the trophy in any
cosplay contest and also a new recurring
character in the newest season of
american gigolo it's jay washington
what's going on my man congratulations
by the way thank you villains all day i
just want to
say we we're not going to do that i'm
the resident's true villain i wore my
shirt with my white socks hat that
matches the infinity stones old saddles
all day you know what i'm saying look
there's
still but i digress
yo og villain jay washington he knows
you know he's where it began he's where
villainy began let's go and finally
selling knock-off t-shirts in the
parking lot at every con guy it's ice
cream producer brandon what's going on
you know baby come and get me come and
stop me
i got i got captain south america i got
the hilk i got uh
the gray widow i got all your favorite
heroes on t-shirts did you say brandon's
avengers shirts are spelled a v y n
[Laughter]
it's how we avoid the lawsuits it's
smart but anyway episode one of ms
marvel gave us the origin for her powers
in the 616 live-action mcu universe and
there is clearly something about those
powers and that bangle that her mother
is hiding and so that leads us to our
first topic of today what is the deal
with kamala khan's grandmother because
the way kamala's mom muniba talks about
her own mother seems to indicate that
there was some deep family secrets here
but if muniba knew about the power
sealed inside of this bangle why was it
just left so casually in this box that
she just sent over the mail that could
have gotten lost like what is the super
secret superpower history from this
family take it away guys well you could
have it it may have because now we're
going cosmic mystic everything with
these this phase of the mcu so there may
have been a mystic thing about it that a
family member maybe uh kamala's mom had
something about it and it almost went
wrong
and so it's like no don't it's just now
it's just junk just put it away and
remember it was mixed in with a whole
bunch of other jewelry so it wasn't like
it was just here take this bangle get
this out of my house because you know my
parents said get this out of my house it
wasn't that it was here
it was hill some bracelets he got some
costume jewelry something you wear at a
masquerade party this mystical bangle
and then it goes some candy like it was
all in the box
i would have loved if kamala's grandma
just accidentally put that in there with
all the junk that she was trying to get
rid of her garage oh baby i'm so sorry i
sent you that bangle oh no don't put
that bangle on you don't that was
supposed to stay on the shelf in the
garage
i think her grandma's a cree i think her
grandma's a cree
and i think they don't like
like a straight-up cree alien
that
that made love to a human man
[Laughter]
then stop this grandma then stop this
grandma then stop this grandma oh
grandma
[Music]
[Music]
we're switching out just to crease
summer
no but i think she i think she i think
her grandma was cree and i think she
when she came down because there's also
talk in the comics how um they can get
their powers from cree technology but
also through genetics and that she might
have possibly been spliced or she has
the genetics of cree that was from ages
ago when cree first came to like earth
so i do think that her gran i think it
would make for better storytelling if
her grandma was just a straight-up cree
now that we're getting into the scroll
invasion um that she's just straight-up
cree and that
they didn't really maybe her mom had to
go through the grandma had to go through
so much trials and like tribulations
just because she wasn't what the husband
was so that's probably why the grand the
mom doesn't want to talk about it the
mom was like my mom went through a bunch
of stuff
go oh go ahead
so what if what if kamala's grandmama
was a creep but she was like a hot
[ __ ] cree right she was the car and be
a creep
she was the cardi b craze right she was
out here busting that creep open right
here
cardi b creases busting that party
then her mama was like you got to get
about my house and she was like i got a
man on earth e-a-r-f and she was like
you got no man so she on earth and so
did she go and she come back with this
bump like you ain't gonna be at my house
it's cr you know what i'm sorry oh my
gosh
i would watch this 90s romance movie i
could totally see it happening because
like we know that like in the past that
like ego was like banging meredith quail
and like different aliens i feel like
could come to earth and have babies with
us like i feel like it just makes sense
yeah well that's the thing in like
marvel comics right that like earth or
life throughout the galaxy shares like a
base dna so it's able to like transfer
to each other they're able to like
procreate i think there's like something
up obviously there's something up with
with grandma there's maybe something up
with mom right she she packs that food
really fast and he's like how did you do
that how did you pack that food
that's my secret you know you're the
tech boy that's my secret but i also
think dad dressing up as the hulk is a
tale i think dad's got a little power
too he's just fun
no i think he has a little super
strength that he's he's keeping in i
think that's what makes him such a nice
caring man because he's got he's got a
lot of strength
uh and he's unleashed it before and he
keeps calm and he keeps he watches his
cricket he keeps calm and he just no
he was gonna smash he was gonna smash
zuzu he was about to snap
you're such
this is where i disagree with brandon
but i think brandon you're on the right
track um like your teacher brandon
you're on the right track but i don't
think i agree so i think the dad is
excited and static about things and it's
so easily excitable because he's like
this is crazy to me but the mom who
knows is like this isn't crazy to me
this this technology life ruined my
family like if the grandmother was just
creating it yeah if the grandma was
creating the cree tech watch would be
like it buried my mom like this is not
what we should be doing we should be
happy to not be superheroes we should be
happy to be civilians because then we
don't have to risk our lives every day
doing god knows what so i think that's
why the dad's like look at this
technology that bruno made and she's
like i don't really care like i've seen
i've seen the sun
freaking engulf us planet like four
times like it's like i think she's
really does that what
what type of mephisto manifestations are
you doing
you know what i'm
no here's it's hard for me because i've
seen episode two already
you know what i hate
every single goddamn person has seen the
second episode above me and i told y'all
that new rockstars that i read all the
damn comics
no one gave me a view of the second
episode
i watched it at a groundhog bus station
okay leave me alone
i was on a bus from birmingham to
indianapolis anyway uh but i know so i
won't go into depth with it but the
story of how further back with the crees
could play because there is some things
about it with again we're getting bigger
into the indian muslim culture within
this we we see a lot about that so it
does play something but the cree element
because of everything that's happening
and how when the bangle goes on her at
avengercon it expands and in the midst
like it reads her dna it's like maybe
nobody else could put that on except
someone in that family like if if mt if
you want at bengal you just be having a
heavy wrist but
i feel like oh
i'm suffering from success
look at my eyes look at my eyes
it read her dna because if you remember
she had the blackout moment
she had that blackout moment and she saw
this there's a bunch of people which may
be ancestral in some way um i think that
as well i think i think that she
literally dropped into an ancestral
plane of her
family like everyone that used to wear
the bangle i now i disagreed with john
earlier about this but now i see it uh
mainly because jay said it and it makes
sense um that the ancestral plane and
possibly see i like the dna being
attached to her
race bracelet and that's probably why
the mom already knows but the dad
doesn't it's like it's the mom's jeans
it's the mom's side of the family it's
not the dad so like that's why and then
the comics the
i hate you in the comics the brother and
the brother also
he gets super powers briefly and so i
think the the sun also has it the sun
can do it um and there will probably be
an episode where the sun puts on the
bracelet it's like what the hell and
like has the super powers that she has
my thing my thing is too with all these
with all this marvels right we know
we're gonna get uh the marvel's film you
know you have captain marvel who gets
her powers from the power stone inside
or the space stone i'm sorry inside of
the tesseract you have uh maria rambo
monica rambo who gets her powers by
going through the hex which came from
like the mind stone i'm wondering if
like kamala's powers are tied to a
different infinity stone like if uh
because she can like embigging and stuff
if that's like a power stone thing
or if that's like a a soul stone thing i
don't know her eyes did glow orange
right which is like soul stone color
what if the bracelet is part of a giant
intergalactic jewelry set with the ten
rings
because
they're reaching out to somebody okay
i actually did make a video about this
yesterday remember i didn't even see i
just want to let that be know i don't
even see this
i don't know he he hasn't even seen it
like that's actually amazing like what
if it's part of like for a black like a
bit worse than intergalactic jewelry
said because the ten rings the ten rings
may be actual rings for something giant
we've seen what celestials look like the
hand of a celestial coming out of the
ocean is our mountains right so and
we've seen that the ten rings can't
expand
because when they're in a little the
breaking when winner in the case or one
thing and the bracelet expands so what
if this is all again this is all this
cosmic thing this is part of something
big a giant we've done our infinity
stones and so that's why the ten rings
remember initially that's why foggy
didn't want to do the rings like the
mandarin did it in the comics and the
cartoons because he didn't want to do
the infinity stones type deal again
so this could be part of a giant
galactic set i love that there's just
like a pawn shop in space that has
he's like he's like best i can do is
350. that's the best yeah
you got to play station five you gotta
play stage five no i got 27
i gotta call an expert to make sure
these are actually the rings yeah yeah
i don't know much about the cosmic rings
uh i gotta call an expert yeah you know
how like people say that thanos looks
like that guy from that pond
stars
that's not gonna do
37 dollars
that's how he got the infinity gauntlet
he went to a pawn shop on asgard and he
was like oh we got there well we got
there do you think do you think the
scarlet witch's tiara is part of this
like power set like that's the evil part
of it did it grow on her face she
manifested that she created yeah i think
she manifested but it's part of the it's
part of the uh the prophecy we see it in
the picture the the the person in the
picture right true or maybe there was
like an original one that got destroyed
by
another witch or something and now she
can manifest it i i had a little sister
i played a lot of pretty pretty princess
you got all the good you got all the
good jewelry but then you got that black
ring and that's the evil part you got to
have the evil part that comes in you
know what i mean i like to think that uh
wanda had a little tiny red tiara in her
brain that the mind stone made bigger
which is the first it's a two major
it's a brain it's not the tumor it's not
i honestly feel like and like this is
like going to the video i made the other
day like the vibranium meteor that came
to earth like a long ass time ago
had all of these items in it we had had
the ten rings in it it had the maybe
these cosmic bangles in it and maybe
even possibly um moon knight's little
crescent that he has on his chest that
like could be the source of his power or
like i don't know that's just like a a
weird little theory i have i just feel
like we're going to be seeing
all these artifacts that are appearing
on earth that blade has to come collect
like you we have the um do you have any
sword they have any blade yeah
and he's just like hey i need to make
sure that people don't die from all
these weird things first first of all i
don't like i don't like blade being the
repo man of the mcu
hey bro i need you to go ahead run that
[Music]
like
hey man uh i feel like he's the best
repo man to have honestly because uh if
you don't pay you're gonna get gutted uh
i'm just gonna tell you that what type
of issue
why would you buy something from anybody
if you don't pay you get good what is he
the mom
hey you know you say listen your burger
was 7.95 now i'm telling you give me
732. my man blade over here gotta take
care of you take care of me take care of
you like no
no he's got a bunch of he's got a bunch
of dvd players that fell off
[Laughter]
but yeah i definitely feel like these
bangles are for sure some type of alien
technology i really like the idea that
um that kamal's grandmother is a cree
and like she's just secretly hiding it
because we saw in captain marvel that um
the crees can look just like us because
we have um the koraf the pursuer um who
was uh in guardians one and uh captain
marvel uh i forget the actor's name that
plays him
from black diamond jaman hanson yes
amazing the man who is in every movie
everywhere we're talking we're talking
blood diamond we're talking blood man
where is
the man brandon talked about him
yesterday and i was i'll be honest i
butchered the hell out of his name
i can't say it first time i said his
name i was like dijon mustard i'm like
oh that's no way okay i was gonna say
that's what i said yesterday but thank
god i didn't say it yes
we love you you're a razor guys
whatever his name was he looked you know
like an earthling
like they call the white cree the pink
skin cree and uh the blue cree the free
and like it's a weird like
it's a weird racism thing happening at
the creek so oh creed segregation out
here we talking about that like straight
up like the cree like are not nice
i mean that's the thing that crete do
they they're not good they're not good
people you think they're more advanced
but they're actually not they're just
like us they're just like january 6th
anyway
where was ronin on january 7th 6th
that's my question they're storming the
hive mind they're storming the hive mind
they're storming
the supreme intelligence
but yeah no i i love all these theories
of course like i really i really like
the theory of um kamal's grandma being a
cree which is why i'm going to give jess
25 000 points uh for that one because
like it's a real good one um and also
i'm gonna give jay another 25 000 points
for just his like i i really do think
that these are alien in nature and they
could definitely be part of that set of
the 10 ring set and like maybe kamala's
grandmother just inherited these um this
artifact for over like thousands and
thousands of years and like she was just
one of the long lines of people that got
it which and also it would make sense
considering that you know when we wanted
to pass down the ten rings to
shang chi when he was old enough they
were strong enough rather um i i mean he
didn't want to give up the ten rings at
all considering that uh he was an old
man and didn't want to die uh but yeah
i'm going to give you 25 000 points for
that because i really like that theory
and what was yours brandon dad strong
dad's strong oh yeah strong dad
um and like
dad's in on this too and like hey and
considering that you know in the comic
books i think that jess alluded to this
earlier um kamala's brother does have
green powers after being exposed to some
terrigen type mist i wouldn't be
surprised if kamala's dad had some green
powers of his own so i think that's a
fun little rogue theory um so i'm gonna
give you
[Music]
25 000. why not i feel like these are
all great theories um
i like to build up suspense you guys all
just got a participation trophy but i'll
take it
well since you're here we don't want you
to feel sad
i'm an elder millennial i'll take that
i'm too nice to be giving out money to
my friends all right
that is it for this first topic and up
next we are going to talk about the
profit margins for earth's mightiest
heroes but first do not miss out on your
chance to grab our obi-wan kenobi themed
latest obsession shirt on
empire's most wanted it is a mid-amazing
shirt but like our all of our latest
obsession shirts once the shirt sells
out it's gone for good like a jedi
frozen in amber what the hell was that
about i think they're cloning jedi like
jurassic park and when you purchase this
latest succession shirt you unlock the
ability to get a custom shout out on
wikileaks our obi-wan kenobi aftershow
hosted by eric voss and tommy bechtold
so check out all of our awesome merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
and hey it can be hard to see the light
at the end of the tunnel when you have
high interest debt i have a lot of that
it sucks and sometimes it can be even
harder to ask for help that's where
upstart comes in upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom so whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses upstart can help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows that you are
more than just your credit score
upstarts model upstarts model considers
other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided on your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
and you can check your rate in minutes
for loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars without impacting your
credit score and you can even receive
funds as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan so don't wait and
check your rate today at upstart.com
rogue theory that's upstart.com rogue
theory to check your rate today and
don't forget to use our url to let them
know that we sent you loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com rogue theory we also want to
thank our partners at athletic greens
zach tommy myself and other new
rockstars team members have started
taking their ag-1 every day to improve
our immune systems and increase our
daily energy we love how conveniently it
fits into our daily routine as well as
how great it tastes one scoop of ag1 and
just a cup of water provides 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole food
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day i
honestly love it because i can make it
quickly in the morning before work and
it supports mental clarity and alertness
all day i feel great it tastes great
it's awesome athletic greens uses the
best ingredients based on the latest
science with constant product iterations
and third-party testing and for every
purchase they donate to organizations
helping to get nutritious food to kids
in need including no kids hungry right
here in the u.s it's just one scoop of
ag-1 and a cup of water every day that's
it no need for a million different pills
and supplements to look out for your
health to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit
rogue again that is a athleticgreens.com
rogue to take ownership of your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance moving on to our
next topic ms marvel gave us our first
look at a fully commercialized world of
the avengers probably the most realistic
thing the mcu has done to date and let's
be real uh if superheroes were real it'd
be more like the boys if anything
because they'd be all commercialized
which leads us to our second topic and
for today every
[Laughter]
i mean hopefully not like the boys uh
ten minutes into the boys season three
because that's that was not that's not
great for the boys you know what i mean
um but anyway
which leads us to our second topic for
today who owns the copyrights for the
avengers because someone is making money
off of avengers con and the avengers
license so who is it like does scott
lang get any kickback for the constant
use of his likeness or is it the
government or the military that owns the
rights of captain america since he is a
product of the us army and the ssr and
what about the off-world heroes like
captain marvel and the guardians of the
galaxy and wouldn't an avengers con be
larger than huge fan events like
comic-con and star wars celebration what
do you guys think i was so suspect of
avengers con that looked like pleasure
island in pinocchio where you walk into
the hulk's mouth and it's this like
spinning thing you're on a military base
and you walk into the hulk's mouth and
it looks like they're trapping children
inside of there that was the most
suspect it's at night who has a
convention
it's at night by the way yeah and it's
in a little warehouse i thought the
building was gonna take off and just
steal all those children like that was
the most messed up thing i've ever seen
it was the first one the very first one
so maybe people are just on the fence
about it people are on the fence about
it there were cosplayers making money
there's a cosplay in drax that has
people coming to his table exciting he's
signing things the exciting thing these
tracks is all the world i think
i think one of two people own avengers
con
it's either a pepper potts because she's
still alive
and look she's making money for her
daughter look morgan start look i love
you three thousand but three thousand
bills too uh is he the pepper
or somehow some way justin hammer oh i
like that okay
i agree with jay i but i think it's
julie
louis-dreyfus it's his character
oh okay
because she oversees justin or no she's
not justin she uh mayonnaise daddy
what's his name
uh
listen he's fine he's gonna
can exist jessica jessica loves a
villain she loves a villain i love a
villain i mean this is also slightly a
very
different villain um i would argue
i don't like this kind of villain but
but
we could get into that a different time
i just don't this is a different villain
i like the fun ones not the really kind
of the race not the billy's from
stranger things
yeah not the billy's from stranger
things
but i think it's i think it's them
because we also talked about slightly on
the break room once that there's a
possibility that when um
iron man died his assets were liquidated
like when like pepper pots would
probably be like i also don't want to
deal with this like my husband just died
i'm a single mom now like i just want to
live as a mother and not think about
superhero stuff because my husband's
dead and he died
being a superhero like i pepper potts is
the most set for life single mama in
history okay
we also need to remember that yes she is
and she is powerful she's great but we
also this is gwyneth paltrow we're
talking about so what accounts so
goof candles are not really
smell
this is the secret room here i i think
it's also owned by someone uh bad and
high up because now that the avengers
are gone they don't really need to
listen to thunderbolt they don't need to
listen to any of the rules anymore civil
war was all because they had to like
come in agreement sign a contract with
the governments now that the governments
don't like now that the avengers the
original ones are gone i think the
government's like oh we can take over
these like
couple of leftovers hawkeye's gone uh
the two are dead uh
three are dead uh like no one thor is
gone like no one knows where any of the
original avengers are so they can just
the government can do whatever the hell
they want really they can't see more
people obadiah
son
who's coming up
okay
or sonny birch's boss that we never
figured out the mysterious okay i feel
like it's gonna be roxanne i feel like
sunny birch's box is roxon um the roxon
people or uh what's his face uh minotaur
from the rockstar no the ceo yeah yeah
it's it's somebody because again
if it's not somebody we've seen because
i think it's too obvious to be somebody
we've seen i mean but again obvious
always happens but if you tell me it's
ezekiel's thing because he's about to
pop up an iron heart you know what i'm
saying he's popping up in iron heart and
then suddenly we never we never saw
sonny burch's boss in ant-man and wasps
so it's like and he wanted quantum
technology
you don't just want regular stuff you
want quantum technology which means you
got money
i think ezekiel would be the overseer
overall i think sonny burch would be
running this shady ass adventurous
client
because it is it is in like a garage and
like everyone's in weird like minecraft
boxes what was that it was at camp
lehigh it's on the military base oh it
is yeah it's on the base where they made
it's on the base where they made captain
america which makes me think it's the
government but i also think i think
we're going meta here i think in the mcu
disney has bought the rights to the
avengers i think this is like
i think this is like how on the boys we
saw butcher using amazon this is disney
is going to be like we bought the
avengers inside of the mcu we now own
them there too we we bought avengers
tower i mean they did give us a bunch of
shirts we've never seen before you bout
y'all ain't seen a bunch of asgard pride
shirts running around here already
like it's a bunch of shirts they made
merch we have not seen specifically for
avengers con at disneyland here in
california they use the costumes from
the tv shows when they put them in the
parks like because they don't have time
to make new costumes like when they had
sam wilson captain america it was the
costume from the show in the park
it's it's the snake eating itself okay
we're we're just in this like aurora
boros of disney owning everything and
now they're owning our fandom from
inside the fandom it's coming from
inside the house
i would love if outside of avengers con
there was a sign that says no spider-man
cosplayers because disney doesn't own
spider-man you didn't see any spider-man
at all
at the end of thor love and thunder
there's gonna be a post-credits scene
and you're gonna hear a voice and it's
gonna be ha ha fine i'll do it myself
and it's gonna be mickey
he's coming
would love if just kingdom hearts 2
mickey mouse and the black robe just
came out of nowhere just to fight gore
the god butcher
south park was right south parker was
right he mickey's going to show up and
just beat down uh all the avengers it's
going to be
terrible huh pooh you think it's funny
you think it's [ __ ] funny
yo when mickey mouse was beating up the
jonas brothers i was crying
jessica they're fine they're fine i love
the jonas brothers um
i love the jonas brothers they're really
nice but like it was just really funny
to see mickey mouse be so out of
character i want a scene at avengers con
where they do like they premiere like
new footage of a new like marvel
property and it's just like a white man
and a baseball cap and they're like hi
i'm kevin feige or they're like makeup
but they're like like but i don't know
when they made fun of it and it was like
i'm a white guy in a baseball cap and
i'm here to talk to you about the new
features that are coming to your
platform remember spider-man
they had chris evans troll all of us as
captain america he was like so
you're here waiting on the post-credits
scene i know what it feels like
it would not surprise me kevin feige
shows up thomas hi guys i bought this
[Laughter]
i'm iron man now
look at me
armor awards just ends with kevin feige
as the winner and then he turns his cap
backwards
that's how you know it's business
[Laughter]
i don't understand how they
the people who live off the planet they
got rockets should be suing you know uh
uh star-lord should be suing
100
like rockets all about money rocket
wants his money yeah but who gonna
represent a raccoon in court who gonna
represent cause the judge gonna slip up
and say are you jennifer walters
jennifer walters is gonna represent him
in court okay so the judge will slip
true but the judge gonna slip up and say
ma'am are you representing the [ __ ] and
everybody's gonna be like
dismissed
it could be it could be uh kate bishop
because she's still a big fan of
marvel's and so maybe she used her money
to like just create she's rich she got
money yes this is the correct answer you
win
you're only saying that because it's
haley steinfeld
what i don't even know who that is
oh crap
what what do you mean haley's haley
[Laughter]
sorry um but no it just makes it because
like she her family's rich and her mom
is super mega rich so i could see um
eleanor bishop oh like owning all of the
avengers con assets and stuff because
she got the money like that i mean again
there's no hawk out there either
so like
you know it was getting [ __ ] dress
but if it's kate bishop hawkeye's going
to be front and center let's keep it
real she loved him more than any other
of the she she's cool of the avengers
but she loves hawkeye more than anything
i think i don't think she's doing that i
think she's just like i i want to give
hope to people and i'm going to give
pope to the kids by doing this in
hawkeye would be all through it it'd be
a bunch of them weird-ass masks all over
the place she's letting them choose she
doesn't and maybe also she clearly if it
was me i would be like no hawkeye's my
man like that's my idol i was trained
under him we have the same outfit we
fight together y'all can't have hawkeye
y'all sound like a couple at six flags
i feel like if if uh kate bishop owned
the rights to the avengers con there
would be a lot more larpers there
exactly well they are larvae i mean
there were a lot of no no sure we talked
about this like superhero lockers just
like regular like medieval libraries
somebody from the fire department just
like hey i gotta get back uh
i miss like three fires for this [ __ ] i
steal stuff from people's burned houses
i'm a fireman that's messed up that's
messed up but no these are all like
again super good ideas i know i say that
all the time but like you guys are super
smart i love you guys um but like the
idea with pepper potts owning um olivia
avengers con is really smart and it
makes sense considering that she would
want to preserve the legacy of her her
dead husband no rip tony starks
sorry
that scene and falcon and winter soldier
is me where i go to get my loan and they
say no so i'm just saying
i'm just saying
is pepper potts getting denied loans
that's what i thought
and we see what side mt is on pepper
pot's side
i am not on the side of the goop you
take that back um and with juneteenth
coming up mt how dare you
i i've
my kind i know um but no i really like
the idea of pepper potts potentially
owning it um and all you know obviously
obviously all your other ideas so i'm
gonna give you 30 000 points for that
one my friend because you are a smart
man and i love jess's idea of val
potentially owning avengers con because
like she's obviously setting up some
type of thunderbolts like fake avengers
situation so like i would love if she
owned avengers con just so she can use
it for next year to like throw in her
some of her people in there like oh you
guys wanna cosplay his u.s agent go
ahead he's the best right he's a little
bit unstable but that's what makes him
fun after he watched his best friend get
hit into the crossroads he's okay he's
fine people are gonna dress up as
[Laughter]
rest in peace lamar um so
[Laughter]
they're like can i take a lamar can i
take a photo okay take a photo
[Laughter]
sure one two three there we go yeah can
we get all the dead lamars to the
the fallen battle star contest all right
um oh damn
and it's gonna be one person bit like
this
i mean that makes it very easy to do
zombie lamar zombie lamar makes a lot of
sense there he's he has a crick in his
neck though he's got a crick in his neck
he's like i like that all y'all are
standing up straight and my neck
i'm going to give jess 35 000 points for
that one because that is very very
creative but this idea of disney owning
all of avengers con is just really meta
and i really like the idea if like
mickey mouse is just like i own all of
you
and everything um and so yeah i could i
could totally see that happening it'd be
hilarious so i'm gonna give brandon 40
000 points for that one
rogue the rogues thing maybe we've ever
done just kidding but like it's pretty
dang rogue but it's still anyone's game
as we move on to the rogue question are
you guys ready for this let's do it all
right oh man
i hope you guys like i'm still thinking
about dead battle stars convention
well speaking of uh dead things
dinosaurs because with jurassic world
dominion arriving in the box office this
weekend this could be the final intro
where's the lie where's the lie
where is the line
you know nothing more fast dinosaurs
never exist all the bones okay by
science okay
okay weirdo keep that to yourself the
earth is six thousand years old
yeah basically that's what the bible
says yeah look here
jesus jesus ain't seen not nam
pterodactyl okay adam and it was adam
and eve not adamant tyrannosaurus like
do you guys want to hear my theory what
if adam and eve were in the pod that
smashed and killed all the dinosaurs
my girl wrote theory my girl
yeah i've always had this like secret
like like i don't know head can and that
venus like the twin planet to earth used
to have people on it and then like the
people went to earth and like maybe
venus i mean maybe adam and eve came
from venus
and they were the only team and they
survived they killed all the dinosaurs
they left all that gas back what we're
trying to say is uh jesus christ not
totally off
that's only off not completely off you
guys read into it right into it this is
a theory channel make your own theories
uh but yes no with jurassic world
dominion arriving in the box office this
weekend this could be the final entry in
the sixth film jurassic saga but if we
know anything hollywood loves a reboot
or two or three or 17. so pitch me your
rogus version of a reboot for the
jurassic franchise that the studios will
roll out in a few years okay
okay jurassic world jerusalem this time
they bring back a dinosaur jesus
jurassic messiah the jurassic messiah
all of a sudden it's
it's a velociraptor though but he's like
the velocity
and so these
[Laughter]
the mesozoic messiah okay well i have
one question is your dinosaur black or
white
he's great
[Laughter]
my jesus got hair like
will lambswool the bronze clay and my
dinosaur is named earl okay
my dinosaur smokes menthol cigarettes i
don't know why but he is stressed god is
good or
or this
pastor is good all the time all the time
all the time
i don't want to hear a single comment
from y'all saying that we're that we're
too woke because
on this channel we're not too old on
this channel we're actually we we
recognize we recognize those different
platforms different things yeah we
recognize the earth's only six thousand
years old we recognize it
i want
i want to reboot i went little reboot
but i wanted to do like a western now i
know there's a little bit of western in
this jurassic world dominion but i want
a full western like you know uh they're
setting up a town uh in the west the you
know they're worried they think they
should be worried about the the natives
no no no no they're out there in the
woods and they hear something they're
trying to build a railroad through the
woods but no no no
there's dinosaurs out there baby they
own the west
you got to take them down
and maybe maybe the native americans
they come riding in on velociraptors and
they tear it down yo you can't stop it
no manifest destiny here the dinosaurs
own it all baby it'd be like the western
version of prey yeah yeah
trailer for the yeah right
and it's not science or dinosaurs they
were here the whole time they never went
away they've been keeping them low-key
right they've been able to raise these
dinosaurs low-key so they don't get out
of control you know so they got
pterodactyls on leashes like parrots and
they can talk they say rocker like if
you don't know what the problem
they have a dinosaur just like iago from
aladdin um voiced by gilbert gottfried
uh rest in peace you beautiful man um
but no i love this idea of like a
western i can see like cowboys versus
dinosaurs let's go like i want to see
that in my eyeballs immediately um i
think they should honestly branch out at
different time periods white hat it's a
ridiculous concept
yes
i don't know but what you got jess i
think we should do what did we what do
we have we have a velocipaster what'd
you say brandon you got a western west
you got a western um
i want a romance one um
[Laughter]
[Music]
you don't need to you don't need to in
this film
he said get ready to get d-rex
get d-rex oh my god d wreck me down
it's kind of like fifty shades of grey
but it's not you know because i don't
want it to be so aggressive i still
wanted to be romantic and sensual you
know you want to see the dinosaurs
whipping each other putting black folks
neighborhoods and she goes in to
interview him
and he's like did you eat today and she
goes
and then he goes oh i'll give you
something to eat and then she he he goes
uh to his secretary hold on all my
meetings for the rest of the day
and then that that d-rex comes
flops out this is this is awakening
something inside of me i didn't know it
was there it really is
um
[Laughter]
i i got to watch dinosaurs after this
dinosaurs oh my god i just want to know
how's the t-rex giving head cuz like
that mouth is just open and can he find
a little man in the boat anyway
it's a t-rex and a stegosaurus so the
stegosaurus can help uh i was gonna i
was gonna make it a human and a t-rex
that's what i thought you did that's
what i thought it was i thought it was
good
he's just nibbling he's just nibbling
you don't understand that how disgusting
the mouth of a t-rex are we're still
being practical here
oh
realism come on wow well i uh i
definitely want to see uh 50 shades of
jurassic very soon um it's going to be
hot and sensual and i want to see a
dinosaur get whipped frankly it's about
time
oh my gosh
it's about time what type of sexy ass
triceratops you want to see take it big
daddy pull it off whip it not even with
leather with bamboo sticks take it daddy
and then he does at the end he does and
at the end when he when it climaxes it
does the jurassic park
[Laughter]
well i think we uh did their work for
them i think this is it this is what's
gonna happen next the next reboot um so
i'm gonna give just 50 000 points for
that one that is just straight up
hilarious
and uh brandon i want to give you
60 000 points for yours because i want
to see mia western pew pew pew let's
shoot some dinosaurs with a cowboy hat
but mr j washington i love
and i want to see that religion pop up
because uh it's a i feel like it's the
coolest religion that we could ever have
so 100 000 points to you jay making you
our winner for today's rogue theory my
friend
well done thank you collapse for you
and uh t-rex claps as well
philosophy
what does he say and meet the robinsons
my hands are too small i don't think you
thought you're just playing all the way
through
[Laughter]
[Music]
but yes that is it for this episode of
rogue theory thanks to our amazing
guests jessica clemons jay washington
and off-screen producer brandon support
everything that they do on twitter go
follow them all on twitter and all the
amazing things that they do every day
and support our channel by checking out
all of our amazing merch over at new
rockstarsmerch.com and if you've got
some rogue theories of your own you can
share them on our discord just make sure
you're 18 years old or older you can
click that link in the description to
join us today you can follow me at
mastertainment you can follow the new
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to us on youtube thank
you guys so much for watching we love
you guys so much you guys are amazing
please stay safe and love each other
okay
peace and i'll see you guys next time
bye bye
[Music]
you